how and when did you meet our Rudy ray
are really way more and very first my
very first time in very first time I met
him was downtown LA when I was doing 48
hours we heard somebody wrestling with
like a security person some I said get
your goddamn hands over me oh [ __ ]
that's Rudy ray Moore and that's the
first time I met him and the movie came
to you in terms of a project when
absolute how soon after that I think I
got the idea to make the movie maybe 16
years ago you know 16 years later here
we are yeah well it wasn't quite that
simple but yeah how and when did you
come onto the project and and what is it
taken to get this this bill mate well it
was a very interesting process because
Larry and Scott and I were together we
pitched another movie it was a kind of
an IP blockbuster type movie we all
walked out afterwards John Fox was with
us and we said hey John Fox had worked
with them on this years ago at
DreamWorks he says why don't we do
something interesting and we all said
yeah let's do something interesting
I knew that Ted serranos was you know
really excited about doing something
with Eddie and and so it was kind of
like let's go to Netflix we all get
ready we go to Netflix the guys they're
brilliant pitchers the best pitchers
you've ever heard they could kind of
take the Dodgers to the World Series but
I think they'd rather right but they're
great pitchers we're all ready to go I
say Eddie can you come to the meeting
and he goes of course we go into the
meeting and Eddie comes in in character
he comes in as Rudy and he does Rudy for
12 minutes and Ted serranos looks at me
and says we're done
and the guys look at me and go like we
don't have to pitch just right and back
to Eddie Murphy so this is like the
little engine that could both in terms
of the story my words and in terms of
the project so so how did that carry out
on set and building the team how did you
kind of get this going and going and
going
John John's still one
got it put the team together and got it
going and going like that John and John
Davis John Fox very good yeah they're
the one said quarterback did so I don't
wanna I don't know bunch of there were
sacks man thank you sir they try to do
it I don't want a bunch of the words but
there's a line that uh the movie is a
man who wrote that word and so we're
gonna go to the men who wrote the word
and the fact we refer to the Academy at
the Oscars they always say I always say
it starts with the word right define so
we got you two going so so give us this
Hill forget that so how long Scott first
how long have you been attached and when
the team brought it to you
we're just start with this story and
where'd you want to avoid not going
you're sort of your questions are
pretending this is like a normal movie
that happened in a usual kind of way
this is a very unusual film Eddie and he
met with us back in like 2002 we got
excited then Eddie got us in a room with
Rudy Rudy told us a lot of his stories
and Rudy was very excited movie would be
made we tried to sell it and we got
blank stares and then it went away
because this was like right right after
like Pluto Nash or something then you're
in the studio talking man now I want to
do a Rudy ray Moore movie they were like
oh so you've lost your mind completely
well I think also that executives would
like watch the human tornado trailer and
say what the hell you know they they
would hear all the profanity and I don't
think they realized we wanted to write
the sweetest movie that says
[ __ ] 300 times yeah so basically
nothing happened for 15 years and then I
like like John John was saying we're
meeting we're meeting with the with the
John's
and Larry and I were coming off people
versus OJ and so it's like you know in
this business you're hot you're cold
you're hot you're cold and when you have
these hot moments sometimes you can make
stuff happen okay you can use a chit yep
and so we talked about it in John call
the Betty and man we threw it together
with with Ted at Netflix so so when did
you come on
and just give us is when you came on
board the project well we only had about
six weeks to prep and so we were rushing
around and really looking at human
tornado as
as our template to do this Rudy ray
Moore dolomite look and in speaking with
Eddie and we're because we were making a
film about making a film we didn't want
to go too far into his arsenal of looks
because it wouldn't make sense but there
was enough in human tornado to get the
job done so even now looking back I can
match up these looks in the film with
some real Rudy ray Moore stuff and it's
it's delightful to see that it does
really match up so it took us six weeks
to prep and we prepped as we went and we
built a lot of shoes that were very
uncomfortable platforms and then we
finally built a pair of sneakers lat
forms for Eddie - she made me some
custom-made platforms from a sneaker
because I was in so much pain every day
and she's she's saying you saved my life
oh I'm so I came close to quitting the
movie two three times but it was a long
hot summer and we tried to make Eddie
and the rest of the caster's and lady
read here is authentic as possible and
as comfortable as possible
miss Randolph who was later read to you
and how did you go about bringing her to
life lady read to me I would say is a
prolific woman that you know at that
time when you listen to her party albums
when I first doesn't Sam I was like whoa
this is a lot but what I when I then
continue to listen to it I was like no
this is actually she's ahead of her time
because though it was explicit or sexual
she was actually telling women in that
period where we didn't have right
sometimes it felt like to our own body
you know means sexual rights at that
time we're feeling as though our bodies
and black women's bodies were being
exploited as she was literally
instructing women of how to be
independent how to say what you want and
what you need and to stand by and that
it's okay like she was giving you this
like play-by-play handbook and so when I
discovered that I was like oh okay so
this is a whole you know I mean this is
a
whole nother thing this is not
stereotypical at all this is a strong
woman who from her experiences learned
how to turn lemons into lemonade so to
speak in the meaning so this is a woman
who has gone through a lot but I think
at the end of the day what makes her so
unique and special is she has as Rudy
says there is a light in her and he
meets her at a time when that light is
dimmed but she knows deep down it's
never lost but she meets someone who is
real and sees her in a difficult moment
but she's never broken but sometimes we
just need someone to believe in us and
breathe life into us and just say that I
see you and you can and once he does it
just jumps you didn't mean like and I
really like how that moment is edited at
first I was like what I seemed a little
fast to go to thriller but I realized no
because it was she was already all those
things that's what she needed in that
time in which they first met and then it
was like you lit something in her and
there's no turning back now
you didn't mean and so it's so beautiful
like they're going on the road or doing
a chitlin circuit then boom boom boom
she's doing movies and she doesn't
really know but she's like i'ma do it
and i'ma live my life to the fullest and
I think it's just beautiful because that
was definitely a moment in which she
could have just stopped you know and
just stayed at that bar you know meaning
that would have been boom the story of
Nancy Reid and that would have been
there all these years leading up to it
all these moments so now you got the
cast you got the costumes you got the
money what are the first moments going
at his character like for you like any
any movie starting yeah it was and I
didn't have to do a lot of prep because
I had been a big fan for years and years
now I listened to his album so many
times that uh I literally didn't have to
learn any of that stuff to go do any
knows like just knew it and I had
watched his movie so much so I just just
jumped in when it was ready and in
washing it all come together what was
that feeling of here it all is and well
at first it was a may like I was
gratification that feeling like wow this
is coming together and everybody that
was involved with the movie all the
producers and writers we're all like
these fans are director we were fans so
it was like these guys that the and part
of this little cult following we're
making this movie about this this guy
that do you know I'm from the
underground and it was coming together
and it was just we was loving it and
made two three weeks in I was like hey
this [ __ ] is coming out great this is
coming out good you know and I was just
happy that it was coming out great for
for the people in a in the little Rudy
ray Moore cult for the movie to come
together and for it to be received the
way and for people that don't even know
Rudy ray Moore to respond the way they
have it's just I'm over the moon about
it
congratulations yeah so so John give us
a sense of sort of how you're thinking
about it how are you feeling about it
once you get all this together and in
all these years and all that that's sort
of carrying a thread Eddy last night I
said I've never seen this kind of love
for a movie before and I've been doing
this for 33 years same here movies for I
have been making movies longer than you
is that amazing is it possible if you
make him longer than me movies 38 years
and I've never had a picture that had
usually with me and my movies the ones
that got any type of notoriety or
anything was just you know my what I did
like my performance and if I was funny
or and this is across the board smoothie
is firing on all cylinders and I've
never been in a movie like that where
you know it's the direction and the
Wardrobe and the writing and the cast
and it's just I've never been in a
picture I'd never had a movie and be
received like this as you think about
sort of Rudy ray Moore what do you think
he's thinking about this I would think
that Rudy ray Moore would be happy as
[ __ ] I think because we do him justice
and we tell his story and and it's what
and it's what happened and his stories
his story is extraordinary and he would
love that people heard his story and
thought it was an extraordinary story he
would love that
ladies and gentleman well thank you and
thank the cast and the crew thank you
all yo